when you're as beautiful as Cameron and
I it is somewhere between irony and
tragedy to appear in films where people
can't see our faces and bodies
especially bodies tonight's nominees
nominees represent a field that has made
such incredible strides that watching
their dazzling images is almost as
exciting as looking at us now when Jude
when we're making movies
um wait I'm sorry they didn't fix the
teleprompters okay this was originally
written for Cameron and Jude Law I
stepped in at the last minute thanks
Jude I mean Steve yep the truth is both
Steve and I are big fans of animated
features here are some of the stars of
this year's films to talk about being
nominated and what it means to them what
would winning an Oscar mean to you well
of course it's a tremendous honor to be
nominated with such a prestigious group
and these are all highly accomplished
films they are the best of the best look
at this look at it princess
what's the secret of kells these are all
cartoons I thought we got nominated like
a real movie well it would give my mom
off my back you know like if she said
Coraline go to bed I could say mom have
got an Academy Award or tidy your room
Oscar mom deal with it oh that won't
work will it
Wow just being none of me to just
breathe because a long people will
discover our Philip that's me and I got
to come all the way from Ireland I might
get to meet that nice mr. Martin with a
lovely silver hair like mine oh you know
just to be nominated this moment is so
much bigger than me this moment is for
all the nameless faceless datas who came
before yeah it is this nomination who is
hidden gonna end up on YouTube business
so what does this nomination mean to you
huh what what is that play we'll explore
it now duck Tompa this is not boo get
down hey here a squirrel
here are the nominees for best animated
feature film Coraline directed by Henry
Selick fantastic mr. Fox directed by Wes
Anderson The Princess and the Frog
directed by John Musker and Ron Clements
The Secret of Kells directed by Tom
Moore directed by Pete docter
and the winner is
the first Academy Award and six
nomination for Pete docter
his first nomination was for the
original screenplay Toy Story
boy never did I dream that making a flip
book out of my third grade math book
would lead to this boy it's incredible
being here it's just me right now but
please picture this whole stage full of
the most amazing cast and crew you've
ever experienced Jonas Rivera producer
Bob Peterson co-director you guys should
all be up here with me thanks so much to
Disney and to Pixar Animation Studios
for believing in this oddball film it
was an incredible incredible adventure
making this movie but the heart of it
came from home and to our families in my
case my wonderful parents they were so
supportive my kids Nicholas and Ellie
and my amazing wife Amanda you guys are
the greatest adventure thank you